♪
>> AFTER TAKING A LEADERSHIP
ROLE ON ROOT CAUSES, THE ACTUAL
ROOT CAUSES, TO INVEST IN THE
ROOT CAUSES.
THE OVERALL ISSUE, WHICH IS ROOT
CAUSES.
ON THE ROOT CAUSES.
YOU CAN'T JUST REACT TO A
PROBLEM WITHOUT SOLVING IT AT
ITS ROOT.
>> Tammy: THERE YOU GO ROOT
CAUSES.
A RECORD NUMBER OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE MAKING THEIR WAY
INTO THE U.S., BUT DON'T WORRY,
AS YOU SAW, OUR BORDER CZAR IS
FINALLY GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF
THOSE ROOT CAUSES OF THE TODAY
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS UP VEILED
FIVE POINT PLAN TO COMBAT THE
CRISIS.
OF COURSE, NO MENTION OF
SECURING OUR BORDER BECAUSE THAT
WOULD HAVE REQUIRED SIX POINTS
AND THERE JUST WASN'T ANY ROOM.
NO, NO.
KAMALA BELIEVES A SOCIAL
DISTANCING OVERHAUL IS THE
ANSWER.
SHE WANTS TO THROW MONEY AT THE
NORTHERN TRY AN DWELL TO WIN
HEARS AND MINDS AND ADDRESS
ISSUES LIKE DOMENIC INSECURITY
AND INEQUALITY AND THAT'S
INSULTING TO THOSE NATIONS BUT
WHATEVER.
MEANWHILE REPORTS ARE JOE BIDEN
WILL BE MEETING WITH A GROUP OF
SENATORS TO DISCUSS AN AMNESTY
PLAN SO THEY ARE VERY, VERY
BUSY, OBVIOUSLY.
JOINING ME NOW CHRIS STEGALL
RADIO AND PODCAST HOST OF THE
CHRIS STEGALL SHOW AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR KATIE PAVLICH.
KATIE, LET ME START WITH YOU.
NOT ONLY DOES IT -- AND SHE
INSULTED THE GUATEMALAN
PRESIDENT WHEN SHE WAS THERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW SHE NEEDS TO
HELP THEIR COUNTRY AND PROBLEMS
NEED TO BE SOLVED.
THERE IS THIS EVEN ANY OF OUR
BUSINESS?
ISN'T THE BORDER OUR BUSINESS?
ISN'T THIS COUNTRY OUR BUSINESS?
WHY ARE WE SUDDENLY FOCUSED ON
CHANGING THEIR COUNTRIES FROM
THE INSIDE OUT?
>> Katie: WELL, BECAUSE THAT
WOULD BE SAYING THAT YOU ARE
SOLVING A PROBLEM WITHOUT
ACTUALLY SOLVE AGO PROBLEM THAT
YOU CREATED AND THAT YOU
ACTUALLY ARE BENEFITING FROM
POLITICALLY IN THE LONG TERM.
THE SAME THING -- THEM SOLVING
THE ROOT CAUSES IN GUATEMALA,
FOR EXAMPLE, IS JUST THIS WEEK
THE STATE DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WERE CUTTING TIES AND
NEGOTIATION IN COOPERATION WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
GUATEMALA BECAUSE THERE WERE TOO
MANY CORRUPTION ISSUES, WHICH OF
COURSE, WE KNEW ABOUT BEFORE SHE
DECIDED THE VICE PRESIDENT
DECIDED SHE WAS GOING TO GO
THERE AND TRY TO CHANGE YEARS
AND YEARS OF CORRUPTION IN THAT
COUNTRY.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT THE ROOT
CAUSES OF THE CURRENT CRISIS AND
IT IS A CRISIS IS ACTUALLY A
SCANDAL CONSIDERING THEY ARE
SENDING THOUSANDS OF COVID
POSITIVE INDIVIDUALS INTO
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES WHILE THEY
TELL THE REST OF AMERICA GO BACK
TO LOCKDOWNS AND MASKS AND TO
CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR.
THE ROOT CAUSES ARE COMING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE ROOT CAUSES HAVE COMING FROM
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT GIVES
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BENEFITS LIKE
FREE HEALTHCARE, THAT ALLOWS
THEM TO TRAVEL THE COUNTRY ON
THE TAXPAYER DOLLAR WITH A BUS
TICKET AND A PLANE TICKET
WHEREVER THEY WOULD LIKE TO GO
WITHOUT HAVING ANY KIND OF
RESTRICTION AND, OF COURSE, NOW
WE ARE SEEING THAT 70% OF OR
GREATER OF THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
SHOWING UP FOR THEIR ICE
HEARING.
>> Tammy: SURPRISE.
>> ESSENTIALLY IF YOU SHOW UP IN
AMERICA NOW, YOU GET TO STAY.
THAT IS BENEFICIAL FOR DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE THEY WOULD LIKE THESE
PEOPLE TO EVENTUALLY VOTE FOR
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> Tammy: I HAVE TO SAY I WANT
BOTH OF YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, DESPITE
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS THINK AND
ESTABLISHMENT THINKS ARE NOT
DUMB BABIES DROOLING WITH NO
THOUGHTS IN THEIR HEAD.
TAKE A POLL HOW THE VICE
PRESIDENT AND PRESIDENT ARE
VIEWED.
THEIR UNFAVORABLE RATING, KAMALA
HARRIS 46%, JOE BIDEN 43%.
YOU KNOW, IT IS THAT IS, OF
COURSE, CREEPING UP.
FAVORABLE RATING IS GOING DOWN.
CHRIS, I THINK THIS IS A
REFLECTION THAT AMERICANS ARE
NOTICING, THIS THAT THE BORDER
IS NOT SOME FAR OFF THING THAT
DOESN'T AFFECT THEM.
YOU KNOW, TOWNS AT THE BORDER,
ONE OF THEM IS HAVING PROBLEMS
BECAUSE THEY HAD RELEASED COVID
POSITIVE PEOPLE, WERE NEVER TOLD
ABOUT IT LET ALONE THE CEDING
PEOPLE INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE
COUNTRY.
I KNOW YOU RECENTLY SPOKE WITH
FORMER HEAD OF ICE.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON THIS?
>> HE INFORMED ME THAT WE ARE
ALREADY TO SOMETHING LIKE A
MILLION IN THE FISCAL YEAR.
FOLKS THAT IN THIS PANDEMIC HAVE
ILLEGALLY CROSSED THIS BORDER.
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON OUR
COLLEAGUE SAID WE ARE PROBABLY
ON PACE AT THIS CLIP MAYBE
2 MILLION ANNUALLY.
THAT'S LARGE METROPOLITAN CITIES
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
NOT A ONE OF THEM SAID THE
FORMER ICE DIRECTOR VACCINATED
AND NOT THAT I EXPECT OUR ICE
OFFICIALS AND OUR BORDER
OFFICIALS TO VACCINATED.
THEY ARE NOT DOCTORS FOR HEAVENS
SAKE.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOT INSISTING ON
THOSE FOLKS BEING VACCINATED.
WE CONTINUE TO READ THESE
RIDICULOUS STORIES WILL BRANSON
MISSOURI LAKE OF THE OZARKS HOT
SPOTS.
WE'RE NOT DUMB.
I'M FROM MISSOURI.
THE SHOW ME STATE.
SHOW ME WHAT YOU ARE DOING ABOUT
THE BORDER.
WHICH IS ZIP.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE UNVACCINATED
AS YOU SAID CEDED ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND WE ARE THE PROBLEM?
WE ARE THE ONES THAT NEED TO BE
PUNISHED?
PLEASE.
>> Tammy: WHAT'S INTERESTING,
KATIE, AND YOU HAVE ALLUDED TO
IT VERY PERFECTLY, THAT THIS IS,
PERHAPS, NOT A MISTAKE THAT THIS
IS WHAT THEY WANT.
THAT IT IS A CRISIS AND
STRANGELY ENOUGH, WITH ALL THE
TALK ABOUT CARING ABOUT COVID
AND PEOPLE'S HEALTH, EVEN MAKING
THE TREK, IF YOU HAVE COVID-19,
PUTS YOU AT GREAT RISK.
THE CHILDREN WHO NEVER MAKE IT
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE THE CHAMPIONS OF
THE DOWN TRODDEN AND, YET, THEIR
POLICIES ARE CONDEMNING THOSE
VERY SAME PEOPLE TO DEATH AND
SUFFERING AND, YOU KNOW, AN
INTERNAL TIE MA'AM MIC WHERE
THEY HAVE NO REAL POWER AND WILL
CONTINUE TO BE SICK BECAUSE OF
THE DESPERATION OF WHAT THEY
FACE.
HOW DO WE EXPLAIN THIS BEING AN
ACTUAL POLICY?
>> WELL, TAMMY, THE DEMOCRATS
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HAVE COMPLETELY EMBOLDENED THE
CRIMINAL CARTEL ELEMENTS OF
THIS.
I WAS IN ARIZONA IN APRIL TO
VISIT THE BORDER THERE AND TO
SEE WHAT WAS GOING ON AND WHAT
HAD CHANGED SINCE JOE BIDEN CAME
INTO OFFICE.
THE SMUGGLING UNIT SAID THAT NOW
HUMAN BEINGS ARE WORTH MORE
MONEY TO THE CARTEL IN TERMS OF
TRAFFICKING THAN DRUGS ARE.
AND SO THEY ARE MAKING UPWARDS
OF $25 MILLION A DAY TO TRAFFIC
THESE HUMAN BEINGS INTO THE
COUNTRY AND THEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PERFECTLY
HAPPY TO FINISH THE JOB BY
TAKING THESE PEOPLE AND PUTTING
THEM ON BUSES WITHOUT PROPERLY
TESTING THEM OR QUARANTINING
THEM AND SENDING THEM TO
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY.
NOW, THOSE PEOPLE ARE MAKING A
CHOICE TO PAY THE CARTELS,
RIGHT?
THERE IS THIS BIGGER QUESTION IS
WHY IS THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
PUTTING BORDER PATROL AGENTS AT
RISK OF GETTING COVID.
ICE AGENTS AT RISK?
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AT RISK OF
GETTING COVID AND THEN, OF
COURSE, THEY CLEARLY DON'T CARE
ABOUT AMERICAN CITIZENS GETTING
COVID FROM IMLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OR